it was a mutual respect situation oh
dame scored
uh but it wasn't easy against drew and
that's what happens when the big is too
hot
you see right here you know stephen
that's a tough ask because you have to
have quick feet
with these guards they're so skilled
with the basketball in their hands
now the bell is trying to get the lead
zion coming off alonzo pick right to the
rack yep
that's hard to guard i think he can
finish yeah when you reverse that
picking
that's trouble
[Music]
carlisle always gets into him and he
says he stole everything from me
it'll be lillard i had to bring it up
and he's got their first triple the game
on their second try
difficult of a shot that into attacking
that rim and taking advantage of it deep
triple
damian lillard again that's unguardable
that's unguardable
there's nothing whatsoever that you can
do about that a couple of offensive
boards
so gifted he is such a talent now
zion bouncing around inside to the rack
that if stephen adams gets a hit which
he is you're going to be open at that 10
to 15 foot area
this is a deep one letter got it again
lord there is no
scheme for this there's no scheme for
this this is just talent
they don't call me logo littler for
nothing jen was just talking about
damian
i mean just talking about carmelo
anthony over his last five he's
averaging 19 points a game
this guy's on yeah when a guy's on it
and he's as talented as he's done
there's nothing you can do about this
he's got a step back in the corner
and it's contested hey all right you
know it's only a seven point
right that that that's what you have to
great pass
with the left hand zion will clean it up
and that's the thing you have to do
against teams like this you have to
weather the storm
trying to set things up
spinning away and i tell you the rack i
yes he's going to find a way to get to
that rim one way
and you see you see carmelo anthony he's
all the way on the other side of the
floor he's overloaded and zion
reads it and goes away from the overload
where carmelo anthony is zion off the jj
pick going to the line looking for the
three-point play it's hard to guard man
that is us in a position he's not
accustomed to
and the guy guarding jj in this
particular instance gary trent jr
in a position he's not accustomed to
the strength the agility and the touch
around that ring
now about scored him 28-9 on this
current run
lillard got around bledsoe he's
ready to take a charge but it was a
slick move by damien lillard or
when damien luther penetrates like he
just did bledsoe into traffic tried to
get the design threw it away
now gary trent puts out the off arm zion
blocks her away
that josh gave him an opportunity to
block that ball
he didn't foul it because what you see a
lot of guys do you got the switch to
josh hart
[Applause]
deep three makes no difference damien
lillard
you know what that's when you just shake
his hand man that's a heck of a shot
so damian lillard working with eden
scanner robert covington
the triple is a deep one and it makes no
difference
to damien lillard gibson lonzo and the
length
of covington on the run out it'll be
points off a turnover for damien lillard
in this brand new game the second half
offensive
and zion what a pass by lonzo
the easy one he can't get the first time
second time it'll work he got it
but lonzo looking ahead as you always
brandon ingram coming off the high
screen with hernan gomez
zion thought about it spins with the
jump hook
back up by five inside of ten of the
shot clock on the switch
ingram step back lillard nothing you can
do about that
he dribbled until he got to where he
wanted to get on the floor
so crafty with that basketball doesn't
need much space does he zion
another three yes there's that rhythm
back to back here's
the rhythm i'm gonna use the same word
tonight that i did last night kyra's got
four assists no turnovers in his minutes
on the floor
zion going to a strong side he's got it
[Applause]
it's a tough angle he's still as simon
they wanted to free up jj
instead it's gonna be zion maneuvering
all the way to the cup
how about that handle did an excellent
job the last two possessions
that is only the sixth turnover jj
redick on the up zion makes a
strong move to them that's the thing at
48
but this guy is back and that's damian
lillard leads all scorers tonight with
32
meg boy he really worked up a sweat
didn't he fresh off the bench yeah
is the difference in so many nba
basketball games right now
zion's got a path gets to the cup
big finish 32 for zion once again
together a couple of stops that's a good
read by jj but you're going to have to
put together a couple
against this man right here and right
back at it
the frozen rope lands for damien lillard
man
he's incredible litter coming off the
canter screen
you mentioned that the leonard gomez
trying to stay in front of him instead
it'll be littered all the way to the cup
one point game again final
20 seconds of regulation what's it going
to be
lillard on the run goes to the line
looking for the three-point play
zion did in the first half you know you
almost expect him to dribble the clock
down take his time and maybe take a
final shot
look how early he win the shot clock so
i don't know if he caught lonzo ball off
guard
the fact that he wasn't prepared for